[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studios this is the
ramsay show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money i'm ramsey personality george
campbell joined today by my colleague
and good friend mr ken coleman
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show and we're here for you
america we're taking your calls about
life money career toxic bosses moving
across the country switching jobs paying
off some debt let's go triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call that triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're getting
started with chloe in uh idaho that's
where she is chloe how are you
i'm doing great thank you so much for
taking my call it's so great to talk to
you guys you're such great mentors to me
oh we appreciate that how can we help
today ken is very flattered yes very
nice
thank you um so
i just wanted to give a little
background on myself before i asked my
question so i'm 18 years old and i
recently graduated high school in may
and i'm currently in my first semester
of college and i'm raising money through
scholarships and
doing that for college and
i want to be
not getting in debt i'm trying to save
as much money as i can so i can prevent
myself from getting in debt and my
question is i want to start saving now
for my future and what do you think is
the best option for me as an 18 year old
well chloe you are wise beyond your
years where did you even pick up all
this stuff
um well my family loves you guys in the
dave ramsey show my grandpa absolutely
loves you he's a great mentor to me he
would fit each of us down with us
grandkids and teaches about budgeting
and the importance of not being in debt
and yeah
there you go
well i love that you're studying and
you're going to college what are you
studying there
for my undergrad i'm doing communication
sciences and disorders and i'm trying to
get my master's degree after that in
speech language pathology and hopefully
a doctor's degree if i'm feeling up to
it wow
taking it all the way what do you want
to do with that do you want to be a
speech pathologist
yes yes cool so this sounds to me like
you've got a lot of school ahead of you
which means you have a lot to cash flow
yes
and guess what else that means it might
mean we are not investing until we are
done with school
okay it's hard to focus on three things
at once because what happens is you
start to cash flow school but now you're
investing but now you don't have the
money to cash flow school so then we go
into student loan debt and then we can't
invest later in life because we have
student loan debt do you see how you're
kind of the dogs wagging the tail here
right yes definitely so i i can feel in
your heart that you are you want to get
started investing and you're young and
you want to make the most of the time
we're always preaching about getting
started early with investing but you
have a lot of time ahead of you and i am
i have no worries that you're going to
be a multi-millionaire if you follow
this path if you wait cash flow college
once we have a full-time job then we can
go hard investing 15
and focus on paying off her house and
giving generously
all right how does that sit with you
appreciate all of that is that not what
you wanted to hear pretty well
i mean i would have loved to start now
and just keep pushing at that goal but
if i have to wait then i will wait
once you've got all cash flow then you
can start looking at that but right now
are you working full time while you're
in school where's your income coming
from
it's part time i'm working at taco bell
currently right now
and i'm also babysitting as well so
awesome
well i would focus all that energy on
cash flowing school would you agree ken
yes and i would also caution you chloe
to not just assume that getting a
doctorate or a graduate level degree is
the best move now it depends on which
direction you're going
um and and i you have a pretty clear it
sounds like a general direction
but i really want you to be patient and
be diligent patient to
number one
get through the stage that you're in now
uh diligent to look into okay what is
the best path for me to go forward and
if i've got to have that graduate level
degree i have to meaning there's no way
to do what i want to do without it
then i'm going to do it but do you
always have to uh you know go from uh
four-year to graduate level right away
just you know i i literally spoke to
doctoral students at vanderbilt recently
and honestly i
i thought it was a mistake that they
asked me to come speak to because i'm mr
like education isn't the only way if
it's not the the only way or the best
way don't do it like i'm mr like college
is an experience just makes me want to
throw up
if you gotta do it go for it but just i
want to go to college i think it's a
complete waste of time and money i know
i know freak some people out but i'm an
efficient guy
but they asked me to come and speak to
him chloe because these doctoral
students at vanderbilt these are smart
people by the way is in the area of of
sciences and all this kind of you know
why they had me speak to them why is
that because they had no freaking idea
what they wanted to do with their career
oh but they're getting doctorates they
just kept going so
they bring in the simple guy who doesn't
even have a degree period
and they want me talking to all the
smart eggheads why
because they they're just getting a
degree to keep staying in school and
there is a a growing move in here so
that's a big long speech to say hey
you're 18.
you're extremely young your entire life
is ahead of you george's financial
advice is absolutely spot on but i would
just add hey let's continue to keep keep
our eyes up head on a swivel where do we
really want to go why do we want to go
there what's the best way to get there
is there only one way to get there and
then you make those financial decisions
based on what is going to allow me to
get where i want to go so the investing
will take care of itself but don't over
commit don't assume that you got to go
get all this high education that's all i
want you to hear that's like my little
dad speech because i got kids your age
all
all right thank you so much for that
advice i appreciate it you bet thanks
for that soapbox can i enjoy that well
it's so true because you hear i'm gonna
get my masters i'm gonna get my phd and
you go slow do we can we get a job for a
little bit and get some experience while
we're at it it's a lot of time and
there's a lot of freaking money
and yet we we we tend to remove logic
from education conversations but every
parent i know would go down wait a
second if they were going to spend
a hundred thousand dollars on a car
and they come home and go hey i want to
buy that new tesla that george is
driving and i gotta get it's a hundred
thousand dollars your parents would go
wait a second whoa slow your roll
but you come on go i want to go to
college i'm gonna spend four years and
i'm gonna come out of debt and 125 grand
then go atta boy dad so proud of you
there's an assumption that it's always a
great investment you know why because
it's a great status symbol george
we throw logic out the window because
well it's a status symbol you can't go
wrong with a degree you can't use it
that you can't afford are you saying
that parents use this
to improve their own reputation by going
well my daughter has she got a phd ken i
don't think it's as insidious as that
that's the cultural message that parents
have now
taken on as the norm meaning we've
digested it we go oh well i mean you got
to go from high school to college we
look down our nose at the trades
how many parents are excited to go to
the block party and go hey
we're really excited for buster jr he
decided to skip four-year college and go
to the local plumber trade school
but you should be that proud
if that's what junior's making 70 grand
straight out of trade school no forget
about the money for a second what if
buster jr likes working with his hands
and serving people and fixing problems
and it gives him great joy the lord
knows we need plumbers ken
i can't turn a wrench to save my life
neither can i
so uh there's dignity in all types of
work
and college is not always the answer and
student loan debt is never the answer so
let's make some wise decisions here
let's move slowly and talk to your kids
about this stuff don't let them wander
into this that's how you create the
nightmare we're in today
this is the ramsay show give us a call
triple 825-5225
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com
ramsey to get a product tour today
that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last week we were in phoenix arizona for
two completely sold out events on our
building wealth tour it was hot energy
in the room was palpable it was hot
outside it was hot inside george cut it
with a hot knife through butter my
friend so if you're thinking about
joining us one of these events do not
miss your chance the events in
sacramento and san antonio are
completely sold out so we just have a
few seats left for building wealth
minneapolis on november 10th so if you
want tickets you got to buy them now
don't be mad at me when it's sold out
because you waited too long prices go up
this friday for the events you can still
get your early bird discount before it's
too late it's going to be rachel cruz
myself dr john deloney ken coleman dave
ramsey we'll all be there it has been an
awesome awesome tour we're going to talk
about building wealth in this current
economy and show you how you can get on
the path to building wealth so we've
been to phoenix we're headed to
sacramento november 1st minneapolis on
the 10th and san antonio to finish it
out on november 15th and tickets just
start at 25 bucks that's amazing in
today's economy i would uh charge more
i've told dave this on the air i think
he's given people too good a deal it's
too good of an event well the four pack
is 60 bucks that brings it down to 20
bucks a ticket by the way john deloney
and i do a bonus session before the uh
before the main event starts and that
thing has been going like crazy so there
were some powerful moments in the room
ken a lot of tears shed a lot of
powerful stories shared and a lot of
breakthrough yeah so basically what john
and i do for that we just literally open
it up to questions it's the john dalony
show and the ken coleman show combined
so those early birds the early birds
come and we just open it up to questions
and we never get to everybody they're
people standing in the aisles i love it
well join us 25 bucks or if you do the
four pack it goes down to 15 bucks a
ticket so go to ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve your seats now bring
some friends borrow some if you have to
it's worth it borrow friends not money
definitely never borrow money all right
but i could buy sure just ken sometimes
i'm sure you have so many friends on
instagram
but when it comes down to real
friendships it's just me and you buddy
just holding down the fork all right
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five cheetah joins
us in orlando cheetah welcome to the
ramsay show
hey thank you guys thank you for taking
my call sure
so basically i have kind of like a
two-part question so i found y'all
because i was so stressed out my
refrigerator
refrigerator broke down i didn't know
how i was going to afford it all my
credit cards maxed out and so i started
looking at loans and then i on youtube
and i was and then i came across dave
ramsey so i've been looking at y'all
i've been watching your videos i've been
looking at the baby steps and so right
now my baby step one i saved up a
thousand but i don't know should i save
up more just in case my refrigerator
breaks down
is the refrigerator running
yeah right now it's just relaxing again
i almost want to hit the punch line ken
i won't do it why you should go catch it
there it is
well cheetah first of all thank you for
being one of our new listeners when was
the last time you just took a deep
breath
has it been a while
has life been stressful
it has
well we teach the baby steps in order it
hasn't changed in 30 years and
that's for a good reason
they work every time you work it and
regardless of what inflation is doing
and what what life is happening you need
these quick wins so i love that you
already have the thousand dollars and
you're worried because you've had
something happen in the past that's
triggering you going what if it's not
enough what if it's not enough
that's where this is coming from
yes how much debt do you have
um i have 15 in credit cards and 7 000
in my car 15 thousand on the credit
cards
yes and seven thousand on the car what's
your interest rate on those credit cards
uh
26
hello
on each one all right now i asked you on
purpose i knew it was going to be a
crazy number like that and even you had
a hard time getting that out of your
mouth because it's so painful
the reason i asked you that question is
because that's the answer to your first
question the reason you only put a
thousand dollars in that emergency fund
is just to cover something like a fridge
going out and you could be able to cover
a repair to that well what we've got to
do is we've got to put every extra
dollar
not into the emergency fund but to pay
off the 15 000 in credit cards
my goodness 26 percent on that you ought
to just do the math on that on what
you're paying just an interest alone and
that will get you the point where you're
throwing up in your mouth
now it's a rather graphic reference but
that's what this needs to be
i know i found y'all yeah so hey here's
the good news you can knock this out
okay but that's why you don't put a
thousand and five dollars or a thousand
and
two hundred dollars it's a thousand
dollars now move everything else into
the baby steps that george is you know
gonna walk you through so you how many
credit cards do you have
i have
billboard she had the pause to remember
eight eight credit cards what's the
smallest balance
oh well i've been working on the baby
set so the smallest is 35 and i got that
paid off today
then the next one is 106. and i'm gonna
have the two more paid off by the end of
october nice do you feel the excitement
that you just had in your voice
you see what happened there yeah that
was the happiest you've been on this
whole physiological change in the way
you begin to talk about paying off debt
so what's your income
it is 2 400 a month but i'm starting to
pick up overtime boom
overtime and listen part-time jobs right
now are at a all-time premium in this
economy
yeah i have a part-time job as well what
are you making in that part-time job per
hour
um 15
not enough i keep doing that but i'd
look for something that's paying you 20
22 an hour
you got it i mean we're like we're going
after every extra nickel that we can get
in the door
yeah on top of that have you cut all of
your expenses and i'm picking up at
least at least 20 hours of overtime at
my current job that pays me already 40
hours of
work
awesome oh i like that okay and you're
not investing right now
no uh well
they both automatically already take
401k out it's automatic like you can't
stop that
i have no idea i haven't looked into
that yet let's look into that and see if
they can pause that temporarily so that
you can take whatever amount that is and
be throwing that at the debt because at
26 this thing is going to be a cycle
that will never end if we don't stomp
this thing fast
yeah have you cut up those eight cards
like cut them up into itsy bitsy pieces
well some of them i lost
uh and then the other ones i was looking
at yesterday
well that's more reason to shut that
thing down what if someone's using it
right now
okay no no no no no no no no no no
like as soon as this call is over i
would record it all of those companies
saying hey i lost my car i lost my
credit so i want to close this account
as soon as i'm paying her
i have a little heartburn myself right
now on the lost credit cards i need to i
need some maylocks you meet some tons
again tom's there she remembered the
ate tums live on the air
yeah the citrus tons wow
i love it i've been
she was a great week and i've been
watching every day you are almost
looking off that dave ramsey every
moment the fabulous ones are shipped
brewing sponsorship briz brewing we need
a time sponsor somebody get on the phone
with toms please i'm a perfect
spokesperson for that
well
cheetah is there anything we can do to
help have you been through financial
peace university
no i haven't we're gonna take care of
you about to today tell her what she's
won george she's won one here financial
peace university can nine lessons that
will change the way you handle your
money cheetah so hang on the line
austin's gonna pick up we're also gonna
throw in every dollar the premium
version to connect to your bank account
and help you track every single one of
those overtime dollars coming in you are
going to crush this thing i cannot wait
to hear your debt free screaming yes
this is what i'm here for ken yeah a new
listener who's going
i had eight cards and i thought i was
winning and i started them going i'll
never pay a diamond interest i'm going
to get rewards and cash back and then it
becomes the emergency fund it was just
on fox and friends this morning and they
were talking about the crazy amounts of
credit card debt soaring like wildfire
yeah here we are and all those people
opened it thinking i'm gonna pay it off
every month sure and it's wise because
you get the cash back in the rewards and
here we are
887 billion dollars in credit card debt
as a nation that's where we are right
now yes
20 listen
i did not know
well i knew the rate was going to be
high the interest rate on a credit card
when she told me 26 percent i almost
spit into the mic it was i really held
it back it was
26
these companies are predatory they're
not your friend they're not sending you
on vacation for free they are winning
the game george and it's on the backs of
struggling americans yeah like cheetah
who are paying 26 interest so that you
can brag about your free vacation you
got on credit card points this is sad
george i think we need to organize a
protest in front of all these
corporate credit card i'm here for
buildings american distress we're coming
for you oh yeah i like that
i was one of them ken i used to think
that way and then i cut up the discover
card cut up my amex sky miles and now i
just pay for my vacations myself yeah
and you save your money you save me
money with your house southwest hack
good stuff 160 bucks you say feels good
to take control and you can too america
we're here for you triple eight eight
two five five two two five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this hour you're listening to
the ramsay show
and there's a lot of places to listen
these days we are of course on apple
podcast google podcast spotify youtube
siriusxm iheart amazon music you can
listen to your smart speaker if you're
tech savvy and of course radio yeah the
goat over 600 stations now and can we
get reviews on occasion on some of these
platforms and producer james sent us one
that i thought was very interesting and
it pertains to you do you want to hear
it it pertains to us as i recall that's
right to us as a combo so this is a
review yeah when george campbell and ken
coleman work the phones together it's
like putting root beer and ice cream
together both good tasting products
separately but pure bliss when combined
don't waste your time listening to all
the mushy junk out there if you have
some spare time highly recommend this
podcast you know i've been called a lot
of things pure bliss is not one of your
places not one of them i promise you
i've never been referred to as pure
bliss but i just wanted to uh do you
think you're the root beer or the
vanilla ice cream i think you're the
vanilla ice cream for obvious reasons oh
silky milky complexion
very smooth oh i see yeah interesting i
get some zip and zang to me okay is that
right was that what you call it zang zam
so i don't know who's nobody knows well
that's a very nice review thank you for
that thank you very much we like being
hey so we are your root beer float this
hour and we've been called worse things
yes
both publicly and privately so by the
way i don't know about that because i
don't read the comments because it gives
power to keyboard cowards ooh george on
the other hand likes to hang out
corners of the internet that's what i
call it see all the awful things people
say well ken you know if you only read
the good stuff your head explodes during
the bad stuff no no i don't read any
comments oh okay neither good nor bad no
all right
that's fair yeah that's why you're so
healthy
yeah i i really don't have to worry
about it when i go to bed at night i
feel fantastic about myself it fuels me
but you know here's what i have found
you're two new rods a lot of people deal
with the haters out there but the haters
they are they're drinking their own
poison
they they're hurt people and they're
trying to throw a grenade over at us
right so i don't want to give them any
power i want to give them no credibility
there's actually a bigger lesson here
what's that
the critics don't count
there it is the critics don't count
they're on this they're on the bleachers
of life they're the keyboard warriors
they'd never say this stuff to my face
well there's too many people to help out
there to be worrying about that's the
other thing let's tell what we're here
for triple eight eight two five five two
two five natalie joins us next in
pensacola natalie welcome to the show
hi ken and george how are you guys doing
great how can we help
perfect uh so my husband and i are on
steps four five and six
he is actually leaving active duty
military and transitioning to the
airlines he was hired by several of the
major airlines i feel super lucky and
yes we just have some choices but my
question is
a couple months ago we temporarily
stopped investing to beef up our
emergency fund for this career switch
and now we got it to where we want it to
be so i'm wondering do we continue
investing in our roth iras or pause it
as we
kind of navigate these different waters
of like paycheck um
i know he'll have a
lower paycheck while he's in training
um so yeah i'm not really sure how to
navigate this career transition and the
money is
he getting a steady paycheck
uh he is right now with the military up
until december that'll be his final
paycheck and then after that he will be
receiving pay through one of the
airlines and they have i think it's like
half of what he makes right now while
he's in training
four months okay so starting in december
there's gonna be a four-month period
where he's making less money are you
making any money in that time
i'm not i stay home with my kids great
fantastic okay so so can you guys have
you already talked about what that
budget's gonna look like in those four
months i presume you have since you're
on baby steps four five and six you've
done this well
yeah honestly we really haven't um well
let's start there
okay here's well here's why
we don't need to make a decision
uh
that is
up high until we focus on where we are
right now so pausing the retirement and
all that stuff georgia that's all that's
all baby step stuff i'll let him address
that but i just want to make sure you
understand that we don't create a
reality
based on feeling instead of facts so
let's look at what he's going to
actually bring in from december to let's
call it april or whatever that
four-month season is and then what our
budget needs to look like
let's start there then we decide
uh on on on pausing or or re-upping um
and i'll just ask since i'm already
talking to you
when you pause the retirement 15 baby
step four
were you not at a three to six months or
did you do that to add additional months
to the three to six months emergency
fund
we were more at the three months and we
added it up now we're at like a
six-month emergency just to kind of
again for this career transition just to
make me feel better really so we're at
the six months now yeah what i sense is
happening is the security gland is
flaring and the emergency sirens are
going off and you're saying i'm not sure
we're gonna be okay when the income goes
in half and so that's what ken said is
let's make a budget and put this on
paper and go can we actually afford all
of our bills and if so then we need to
continue investing we don't need to stay
out of the market while these stocks are
on sale so i would get back into it and
if the paycheck's 2 000 we do 15 of
2000. the paycheck is 5000 we do 15 of
5000. so i would continue on and make
that a habit that you do no matter what
unless there's a true storm where he
actually loses his job
that's when we go okay we're going to
pause investing
okay perfect okay thanks so much for the
call appreciate it all right we're gonna
move on to marion providence rhode
island mary welcome to the show
hello nice to talk to you guys great to
talk to you how can we help
um so i well me and my husband because i
am married we have about 35 000 in
student loans but it's all from
me getting my bachelor's
and i mentioned to him like i just want
to get really intense about paying it
off um but he what i mentioned get for
myself getting a second job he really
wasn't for that um because you know he's
worried about our daughter with child
care how is that going to work out with
child care but i'm trying to think of
ways that i can add extra income into
our family
because i want to feel like i'm
contributing to paying it off and i want
it to go as quick as possible so that's
like where my question is like how can i
help cut where we can cut and bring in
income without you know
raising our child care costs are you
full-time caretaker right now for the
kids
um no we have one daughter um i yeah i
mean i take care of her but she goes to
daycare which is already taking up a lot
of our money there okay so you are
working outside of the home currently
yeah okay what's your income
um so our income together both of our
income is about 6 600 a month it's in
flux because my husband's a carpenter
okay is that take-home pay
yeah that's that's take-home pay because
you're taking home 80 grand
and so the question is how much of that
80 grand can we throw at this 35 and get
this thing going really fast and what
you're saying is hey what if we could
take that to 90 grand
what would that do for the day yeah
now as far as child care how does that
affect the daycare
is he just saying hey if you're going to
be gone at night i've got to take care
of her
yeah that's his thing is that you know
like even if i ask families to watch or
my family still expecting some kind of
of kind of you know compensation because
i had family watching her before and it
didn't really make that much of a bit
into our child care cost so it's it's
just a matter of he feels like he can
earn more being like doing carpentry
work versus me trying to go out and was
he willing to bust it and do some extra
work
i feel like he is but i don't know if
he's as intense about getting out of the
bed as i am
so you're not really on the same page
about your goals here yeah
so that feels like the a1
yeah
does he not feel the urgency around
these student loans is that all of your
debt or is there more
no that's that's all of it it's all my
student loans that's it i mean just
outside of our mortgage well it's his
student loans too y'all are married
right yeah so it's our student and he
has said that he said that he's like you
know it's our it's ours now because we
are married but i just
i guess i feel like i
have that charge of like i want to go
tackle it and be quick about it and i
feel like more relaxed with it yeah
you're energized about this well how
about this i'll put you guys through
financial peace university if he's
willing to go through it you think he'd
be willing to do it
i think he would be
well you tell him this is my vision i
want you on board i want you just as
excited as i am so hang on the line
austin's gonna pick up we're gonna hook
you guys up with financial peace
university if he's not fired up by the
second lesson i don't know what's gonna
get through to him
but that's gonna help you guys decide on
what's next and what these side hustles
look like and what child care looks like
but this debt is gone within a year
maybe a year and a half
[Music]
oh that'd be nice you got this mary
we're cheering you on this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined by the host of the ken
coleman show you guessed it ken coleman
we spent a lot of a lot of time and
money on that show we got there
hours and hours of brainstorming to come
up with the ken coleman show landed in a
good place yeah yeah well if you didn't
know folks you can visit us right here
at our headquarters south of nashville
tennessee and we love to have visitors
and occasionally a visitor has a
question and so we put them on the debt
free stage and they get to ask their
question live right in front of us we
like that it's uh for guys like us with
adhd it's a it's a mix in the rhythm you
know
yeah so who do we have on the stage well
today we have lisa and uh you're from
honolulu hawaii i am
what is your question today lisa so i'm
54 and debt free and in a situation
where thanks to ken doing very well on a
new job awesome yeah it's been wonderful
um but i want to make the wisest of what
i'm making right now so my question is
should i be just fully re-funding my
retirement because i am behind
or can i simultaneously
fund my retirement at this age of 54 and
still save for possible purchasing a
condo in hawaii which of course hawaii
is very expensive
and that's probably what i could afford
and i'm thinking initially purchasing it
and then having it as a maybe a rental
until i can take over and maybe it be my
retirement place or do i just throw
everything into retirement how much is
in retirement um about a 120 okay and
that's it you don't have any pensions or
anything else going on is it a 401k
situation 401k and roth and roth okay
are you renting right now i am but it's
a situation with family so
i have the lowest um
expenses that i've had in nice my
lifetime so i want to make the best of
it because i've been given a lot of
kindness from the family which is great
and do the wisest thing so if that
situation changes i'm ready to move into
a possible place that could be my
retirement place
that makes sense yeah well i would want
you to have a paid for primary residence
before we jumped into investment
property how much cash do you have um
just enough for a six-month um my
emergency fund okay so i'm really
starting from scratch with the new job
and
so i'm just looking for that so this
would be yeah so that's my question like
i i can stay where i am for quite a long
time to either save for and it's not
necessarily an investment property that
i want it for but i want it to be my
primary property when the time comes
yeah well i i don't think an investment
property is a necessary part of your
future right now but what i do think is
necessary is catching up on retirement
because i don't want you working till 70
because you don't have enough in
retirement and you've got this mortgage
on this investment property that we're
hoping you know is cash flowing we're
hoping that the renter pays and all
these variables in there so i would want
you maxing out all you can on retirement
anything beyond that i would want you to
save up and get your own place
okay so i guess my question would be if
i'm getting uh my own
uh place would it be uh that would be my
primary residence basically at some
point
okay yeah so i think the investment
property is a is a further down the road
dream yeah and i'm not thinking it as an
investment property i'm just like
primarily when uh getting a property
right now would be too much it would be
50 of my income oh yeah so i would have
what does a condo in hawaii cost yeah
half a million easily no a small simple
condo is now up to let's say three 300
800 square feet but you're in a new job
and i just wonder and i know it's early
on but do you see a path for promotion
and a ladder to where you can grow your
income as well over the next two three
five seven years yes
so your your income increasing is a big
part of this yes right so if we get
caught up on the in on the investing
into retirement
as you grow
right
and i know it's not fun maybe to not
have your own place
but in this situation george i think as
you look to increase your income through
promotion and growing professionally
that's when we can save on a down
payment but getting yourself back into
that retirement rhythm and getting that
caught up is the better move right now
okay because i guess my concern is that
i'll get to retirement and the only
thing i could end up let's say worst
case scenario i have to go into a senior
citizen
i mean not senior but senior housing
where they take your income into play
and then they look and they go oh my
goodness she's got a great retirement
she doesn't qualify for there and i
don't have a place of residence
you know okay so let's put something
that makes sense yes but i think you're
and i think it makes sense but you're
you're basing that question on the
emotion of fear true it's the worst case
scenario you just hit us with yeah okay
so let's just put some real numbers at
play uh 20 down payment on a 300 000
condo is 60 60 grand yep so how long
would it take you if you get back on
your retirement schedule and you're
investing there with with increases in
your income maybe you're taking on a
side hustle
thanks to you there you go so so my
point is how long would it take you
realistically to get sixty thousand
saved up two years
okay then you know that for a fact
pretty sure yeah
a year
while funding retirement
at 15
okay great so that's the thing is it do
i stay at 15 with the smart investor pro
and that's the question george are you
recommending should go above and beyond
the 15 percent no i would still do 15
and based on your income that might mean
you get some of those catch up
contributions you're going to be fine
past 50. so now let's reset let's reset
this okay all right
two years from now you've got your 20
down payment and you have your own place
you're not going to an old person's home
hey i don't want you planning for trying
to set your frame there like that's what
i'm trying to plan yeah but it's like
you you gave the absolute worst case
scenario and that's not even realistic
what's realistic is
uh you're gonna have a down payment for
a condo and maybe even a nicer condo
than you even think in the next two to
three years is it worth two or three
years of waiting and being diligent
absolutely
yeah okay
i'm thinking that the uh actual monthly
payment though would be not uh 25 of my
income that's where the the catch is
because of what has to change so what
has to be true for that to be different
increase in income
increasing income and increase in down
payment oh okay which means you may have
to wait three years maybe three four
five year journey to get there again
none of this has you as an older person
going into a home where they're going
well you can only afford this well and i
don't think that the investment property
is going to be the savior that you think
it is
yeah
i guess i probably worded it wrong i
wasn't looking it as an investment but
initially moving into it wouldn't be
realistic for me at the income i'm at so
having someone rent it until i either
also dump money into it on top of what
they can cover for the mortgage does
that make sense i mean you understand
what you're asking do you understand
what he's asking but no it doesn't make
sense you're better off to do what
george said the fifteen percent okay
bust it at work okay save save save yeah
you're fine biggest down payment bring
down the actual goal is for you to have
no house payment whatsoever in
retirement and then that is an
investment but it's something you live
in and then now you have options but you
also have a really great retirement
account over here where you've done very
very well you've been very very diligent
and then you've got a great home
situation that is also going to pay you
you got this i literally just turned 54
a couple days ago so happy birthday i
need to find this out you're good though
you got a lot of life ahead of you yeah
yeah it's not too late okay good you're
good all right well thank you so much
appreciate you visiting congrats by the
way on the new gig thank you yeah that's
fantastic all right ken this is a big
one i was speaking at a church this
sunday and a guy came up to me during a
break and he was in tears because i'd
mentioned on the stage i said hey and if
you're older it's never too late some of
the most inspiring stories are the ones
who are 70 years old and for the first
time in their life they're debt-free
yeah and a lot of people think well i'm
46 i learned this stuff i'm 52 it's
never too late as long as you can fog a
mirror there is hope for you yet yeah i
agree with that and i think that i love
this question because this is a very
accomplished professional all right and
she's sitting there and she's going
i'm worried that i'm going to have the
government tell me what kind of
retirement condo i can live in because
i'm going to have nothing and that's
real fear fear is
debilitating and so what we did in that
little exercise i i want to make sure
the audience a lot of new people
listening and watching the show what we
deal with on this show are facts
we look at real numbers and we go what's
real not what is the boogeyman
underneath the bed
and it's really important to go all
right let me step back and see
based on my desired future
what must be true
for me to get there
and when we begin to deal with facts we
begin to do two things number one
we're really clear
and that makes us confident
right and then when that confidence
takes place and we go oh it can be done
now i can walk the path
that the ramsey show gives us and then
it's really going to decide am i going
to do it that's right
it's a lot easier to do when you're
confident that it can be done
and that's the social proof that's the
debt-free screams all the success
stories love it that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books my thanks
to all the folks in the booth keeping
the show float and to our listeners out
there and of course to my stellar
co-host ken coleman we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving in storage studios this is the
ramsay show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money i'm george campbell joined by
ken coleman this hour this is your show
america call in with your questions in
triple eight eight two five
five two two five ten moments ago you
were hosting the ken coleman show what
are what's on people's minds out there
yeah well they're job seekers the
employees yeah they're worried about
inflation is a big thing am i making
enough i don't know if i'm making enough
i think they're certainly watching a lot
of people leave jobs and we're still in
this
this cycle right now we're having over
four million people a month change jobs
that hasn't slowed down
unemployment rate is still low but the
fed
we saw that the fed was going to do it
came out
fed raised it 75 basis points so people
are going am i going to get laid off
they're really worried about that fear
and uncertainty a lot of fear and
uncertainty um certainly people thinking
about that obviously and people trying
to make a decision you know should i
leave now
um so we're always talking about that in
the world at work you know they're
watching
other harmful trends like uh today we
reported that there's a new trend where
companies are actually advertising jobs
and they have no intention of actually
filling those positions they for for a
variety of reasons they leave the
positions open because
they don't want to take them down
there's nobody's thinking about it
uh or they're trying to make the company
look like they're doing very well so
it's a pr play
or
um they're actually not intending to
hire they're just maybe hoping a unicorn
walks in and if a unicorn walks in then
they'll go oh
we'll hire you and so that's creating a
lot of frustration for people who are
looking for jobs and they're hearing
crickets so that's some of the stuff
we're dealing with every day well if
you've got a question for ken in that
space you're going hey i think i want to
switch careers i'm at a crossroads i've
got a decision to make i'm in a toxic
workplace give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five i of
course can help with any of your money
questions and that's what we're here to
do so let's get to the phones justice
joins us in tucson justice welcome to
the show
hey george and ken this is so cool i get
to talk to you guys this is really cool
justice we're glad you called in how can
we help
so a little background i'm 18 years old
right now i'm a freshman in college and
i've known this girl for a long time and
we've just reached she's recently my new
girlfriend and she brought up this she's
still in high school but she brought up
this uh
idea of taking out student loan and i
quickly shut her down i've been
listening to you guys for
a couple weeks now pretty heavily
and uh
our future product
huh how did she take it
so she immediately i started to explain
to her she questioned a little bit and
then she ended up saying okay i won't
take it out and this but
uh you know knowing her [ __ ] i don't
know if she for sure wouldn't take it
out but she also is kind of excited
about this college lifestyle that she's
uh she wants to live you know have fun
in college and do all that but i know
having that mindset might be easy to
fall back on a student loan yes so
you're in college right now correct
uh yeah i'm a freshman i'm cash flowing
right now you're cash flow community
college nice i'll see what are you
headed towards
so my or are you talking about my degree
yeah your career where are you going
i'm gonna major in accounting okay so
you're doing what community college just
to get the basics knocked out save some
money yeah to i'm just going to get my
general associates right now yeah but i
get all my prereqs done yeah
it's a very mature question so you this
is a girl you've known a long time and
now you guys are starting to date and
you're in college but you're in
community college getting that
associates
and you're worried that she's all about
the experience whereas you've already
decided that's not what it's cracked up
to be is that what i'm hearing
yeah so
i
am willing like to delay that pleasure
aspect in the college like getting
through and still having fun
and that aspect of not wanting to
jeopardize my future yeah i think that's
the answer to your question
i love george that he he's listening to
the book that he's seen the bard future
documentary
i think you got to sit down with her
i'm sorry
yeah i haven't seen the doctor i plan on
watching oh i'm sorry you said you
listened to the podcast yeah i was i was
in the whole podcast from my own so nice
george i apologize i apologize well
that's a great point though they could
watch it together i think you watch it
together but then i would actually let
her listen like see if she'll just
listen to those podcasts that you
recommend
and then it gets her all the information
in the head that you've got and then you
have some real conversations about it
not heavy
but i think it's about casting vision
like i think you've got to walk her
through
what would happen
what it would look like
how much money she'd have to pay back
realistically how hard she'd have to
work to pay it off quickly
and just let her see the story in the
narrative
nobody hears that narrative unless you
listen to george's podcast bard future
or you the documentary
are you listening to the show
no one is sharing this narrative of like
how freaking hard it is to deal with the
loans on the back end you are better off
just going to europe and having a great
time you could have a luxury vacation to
europe if you're just going for a great
experience and to get some culture yeah
right and so part of this insanity is
we've forgotten the purpose of college
and i love community college because
guess what there is no experience you go
yeah no lazy rivals there you study you
do the tests you leave with a piece of
paper that's it that's all college
online classes that a boy
so look i mean you can go to like george
said you can go travel anywhere in the
country and go to a lazy river for the
weekend and cost you you know four or
five six hundred bucks or a nice hotel
room way cheaper than 200 grand in
students have you seen the videos for
these colleges folks in case anybody's
wondering if it's a game
go go on these any college university
website you want to and watch their
sizzle reel
it's like an amusement park on steroids
it's like summer camp for college kids
yeah i mean that's what it is it's like
give me a friggin break yeah and i think
that you know if she's what 16
okay so at that age you're not thinking
you know where am i gonna go to college
and what's the degree you're just
looking like oh it's the next thing i'm
finally gonna be out of school i'm not
gonna live with mom and dad anymore i'm
gonna be on my own i'm going to have
this amazing experience and that
decision alone will cause people to
struggle for the next 20 years as they
pay off student loans yeah she has
she has the idea of her career and stuff
and like where she wants to be in life
but what does she want to do
like
she wants to go into journalism
cool
hey you know what you want to do this
excitement of that life inner voice or
the college life and i just i don't want
that to default to like
want to take out a loan to make it
easier even like to the point of credit
cards like hey here's what i want you to
do
here's what i want you to do justice
this is really easy to do i want you to
go do the research on what journalists
are making their first couple years out
of college i want you to show her the
numbers like a starting salary and how
hard it is to get into journalism you
wouldn't believe how low they're paid
okay and how hard they work i'm talking
about people you see on tv with a really
nice dress doing the weather well we
have a
southwesterly wind blowing in today
they're making nothing
and and the student loans and then show
her how much that journalism degree if
she takes a loan and what she's gonna
have to pay back versus what she's
making oh baby that'll do the trick
i'm serious man journalism is tough
we've got some folks that left
journalism they're working here now and
there's some horror stories oh i've
heard them because the degree still
costs a whole lot of money in the salary
on the other side you go man this is not
worth it yeah so i hope that documentary
helps we're going to send it to you for
free it's like five bucks but we'll
cover the we'll cover it austin's gonna
pick up we'll get you a code to watch
that i hope that convinces her if not
you gotta go is this the girl i wanna
spend the rest of my life with nope if i
don't align on our basic values that
might be part of it
well good luck my friend hang on the
line austin will pick up this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm george campbell he's ken coleman
this is the ramsay show our question of
the day comes from blinds.com their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more be sure to use the
promo code ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from logan in
arkansas my wife and i are expecting our
first child
but i'm looking at switching careers to
go into the legal field we are currently
debt free except our home and have a
three-month emergency fund my question
is should i delay going to law school
full-time
and continue to work so we do not go
into debt
or go to school part-time and pay as i
go
yes well you absolutely should not
go full time and go into debt
um so delay yes or
cash flow part time both options work
and let me just tell you something the
legal work is going to be there
the legal field is going to keep on
going whether you're in it or not and
there's no reason to be urgent here
you don't want to go into this new field
and instead of being excited about this
work that you've put a lot of time and
effort into in the form of law school
and the lsat and all that stuff
and then be stinking dragging around
that debt on your shoulders all day long
i just i would never go after the dream
job that could be a nightmare because of
the amount of money and stress
and lack of margin and relationship
tension that
debt causes
weight so either
keep working and save up
but i actually like option two better
yeah i think it motivates us a little
bit more when we're actively involved in
it so i'm taking one or two classes
uh and it's just incrementally getting
me there
but i'm tasting it and you might
experience it this ain't it this isn't
for me it could but you know that's a
very interesting point before i'd ever
go into law school i would spend time
i'm talking shadowing lawyers
and they'll let you do it
lunches with lawyers
i i would be talking as many lawyers as
i possibly could before i ever committed
to law school taste it smell it see it
try it
get immersed in it and let me tell you
what's going to happen
once you gather that experience whether
it be law school medical medical school
or any kind of like expensive school
once you experience enough of it your
heart will then confirm if in fact you
should do it
well the first sentence worries me a bit
kenny said my wife and i are expecting
our first child but
and so we've gotta figure out what this
first child you know how that's gonna go
we gotta stack up cash for the baby tell
me how it's gonna go there'll be a lot
of diapers and a lot of sleepless nights
it's gonna be switching careers while
we're having our first kids [ __ ] a
lot of stress here i was switching
careers i had three kids under the age
of three running a small business try
chasing the broadcasting dream sorry to
sound like old school i was waiting for
you to say and i walked up hill both
ways well i did george but no but
seriously you can do it
oh you got to be willing to to commit to
this this is going to be a lot of work
law school is no good yeah but you can
do it all right love it thanks for the
question logan appreciate that let's go
to the phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call we'll talk about your life your
money your career a crossroads we give
you some confirmation we are here for
you here's one george if people want to
talk about getting a bigger shovel
making that switch that career switch or
who doesn't
let's go
that's what i love to help people do
increase your competitive edge it's your
greatest wealth building tool let's do
love it lars joining us up next in miami
laura welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much for having me on
absolutely um i have
thanks i have a basic question that
should we pay off the house but there's
kind of more to it okay
my husband and i are in our 50s we just
got married three months ago
we were both working the baby steps on
our own previous to getting married so
we didn't have any consumer debt i
didn't have a house so i was maxing out
my retirement and i was putting
significant amount of money into a
brokerage account he was on baby steps
four through six trying to pay off the
house this kid has grown
so now that we're married we've combined
our finances but we haven't really made
any other big decisions yet so like i
still have my draft coming out for the
brokerage account
so now we have this non-retirement
account
um but it's down the market's down so
according to the baby steps we should
take that out and pay off the house and
it's just like so we have this big
emergency fund because we both had an
emergency fund and we have this
non-retirement account
so do we lock in our losses and pull
that money out and pay off the house or
do we wait for the market to recover
well i think when you could hang on to
this money for a little while longer and
then throw it at the mortgage what's
left on the mortgage
133 000 and what's in the brokerage
account
it varies up and down you know 123 to
130 over the past couple of weeks plus
we've got the big emergency fund
so what if we stop contributing to the
brokerage account and let's start saving
money separately in a savings account or
you can throw that you know all your
future income towards the mortgage and
then once the balance of the mortgage
reaches the balance of the
brokerage account we cash it out and pay
off the house
in one fell swoop
okay so just when the number gets the
same regardless of the market just pull
it out yeah how much money would you be
losing
how much have you contributed
well 1700 a month and it's
it was 140 last year and now it's 123.
but how much of that is your
contribution
i don't know if i understand the
question well part of that is growth
because you invested it
so you didn't actually put in 140 000 of
your own dollars
you may have put in 112 and it grew to
140 right
ah
yes so i wouldn't look at this as a
giant loss if you put in 112 and it's
now 130 you're up over your contribution
so i'd call that good and i'd go live
free without a mortgage payment
that is amazing i we never thought of
that so i think that will help this not
feel like an emotional loss listen i'm
blessed to be a blessing thank you so
much for the call that's brilliant
brilliant advice i didn't know it was
ken i was just doing you know math no
but so but here's the thing never
thought about that way you gave a
different perspective and it's it's
framing things to be able to make a
decision confidently well this market is
causing a lot of fear ken people are
going well my money's down well you
didn't lose any money until you actually
sell those shares cash out that's right
so there you go think about it this way
yes the market is down but if you
continue to invest you're now buying at
a discount and it goes back up
george i love that i haven't heard that
one in a while we should probably record
that after the show and then use it as a
sound effect going forward i'm sure
james is working hard on james shot that
one down immediately well ken i did a q
a over on my instagram yesterday and
it's fascinating how many people are so
scared right now that they're they're
taking the money moving their money from
their 401k into the cash equivalent in a
money market so they're not cashing out
there's no penalty they're just moving
it out of the market and that worries me
it's unnecessary yes tell people why
well they're thinking very short term
they're thinking i want to stop the
hemorrhaging i want to stop this free
fall right and therefore i'm going to
move it into cash the problem is you're
missing out on buying all these stocks
on sale
baby and so what's going to happen is
the market's going to come back up and
you're going to go oh oh my goodness it
was sitting in cash and i wasn't
invested i could have made so much more
if i had just stayed the course so we
say the only people who get hurt on the
roller coaster are the ones who jump off
early yeah so don't do this really cool
think about that think about like you're
riding the roller coaster and then you
hop off halfway through the ride you're
not going to miss cause you're in free
fall and you go this is
yeah
makes your stomach turn and so what do
you do you go i want to get off this
ride yeah but if you just hung on a
little longer yeah and think about this
too no one's cashing out their
retirement all at once you're only
withdrawing as much as you need right to
live that month that's true so if you're
down you're not taking out all of that
money while it's down you're taking out
a very very small percentage to cover
your bills and so over time we want you
to stay aggressively investing until you
take your last breath because you're
missing out on big returns yeah i love
the uh roller coaster analogy i got a
great roller coaster story for you
george did you go into commercial break
i was at busch gardens one time in
williamsburg virginia and was in line
for a roller coaster called the loch
ness monster hurricane shut the ride
down we wanted to know why they shut the
ride down we find out fabio you know the
uh giant guy with the hair on the back
novel uh the beefcake i can't believe
it's not butter guy i don't know but he
was on the ride and a goose flew into
him broke his nose shut the ride down i
never did get my eyes on fabio and his
broken nose but there's my roller
coaster story i don't even know if i
believe that that sounds like folklore
a goose hit fabio broke his nose at
busch guards flew into him while he was
on the ride it sounds like one of those
weird dreams you tell a friend and i
think that's really true it was reported
in the news the next day you know the
news is never wrong well hey folks you
didn't come here for that but you got it
anyways and that's what you get right
here on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined by ken coleman
this hour this is your show america
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call we'll talk
about your life your money your career
whatever is going on in your world aaron
joins us up next in indianapolis erin
welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
how's it going
uh yeah so i am
your phone is breaking up on us it's
clipping in and out can you get to a
clear spot
yeah i don't know okay well i'm gonna
put you on hold and we'll see if austin
can get you clear and we'll come back to
you how's that sound
melissa is going to join us instead
she's in sacramento melissa welcome to
the show
hi
hey how are you doing
um
dressing out
okay
what's your question
all right hit us let's see if we can
help
all right so um
uh getting ready to go through a divorce
and
the home that my husband and i own
together well you know it's mortgage of
course but um i need to decide whether
or not um
we're going to go ahead and proceed with
um selling it which was our initial plan
or
refinance it
with enough to buy him out
which obviously is
going to increase my payment
substantially especially in this market
and also with adding
the money to buy him out
obviously that increases the price as
well and you know i'll be doing it on
one income versus
um two the other option is um i own a
piece of property um
that has uh an old mobile on it um i
actually moved into a fifth wheel and
that's the kicker i bought a fifth wheel
to live in
um because uh the mobile is um
well it's not it's not that great but
there's not enough room there's already
my father and son living in there
and so
um i could stay
at this other piece of property and save
you know my monthly expenses would be
substantially lower i think i figured
you know after writing it all down i'd
save about 23 something you know about 2
300 a month
by staying at this property
and then do i do that and you know with
the proceeds from the other house if we
decide to sell that along with what i
have in savings and and then eventually
selling this property
put all those funds together and buy you
know maybe in about five years
i would have
more of a substantial down payment for a
home i mean i did a projected savings
and if i only saved
the difference in cost between the two
properties
with all that and just projecting that i
figured i'd probably have a little over
three hundred thousand of course i
wouldn't put that whole amount down um
but very close i think it was about
three three fifty okay and then if i put
three three hundred down then i still
leave me with what i like to have is is
a minimum of six months emergency fund
in case you know you lose your job or
whatever so do you have any debt outside
of this mortgage
i do um i can't yes i have two vehicles
right now
um
i
only have a little bit on a credit card
and that's because it was a zero percent
promotional rate uh build a fence for my
you know i use it for fencing materials
but that's
um i think it's at 32 i just paid 2 200
on it in two months i'm paying another i
was gonna pay another 600. okay what's
up with the two car loans do you need
two cars okay so the two
no one's for my son um he just turned 18
i bought it and he uses it to get to
work and stuff i have enough
just about enough if i sell
some employee stocks which actually
they're on my list of calls today to go
ahead and sell my qualifying stocks and
um
uh i could add a little bit more to that
and pay that one off
um what i'm hearing is you're doing 19
things at once and
your life is already messy as it is so
can i simplify all this for you
sure if i woke up in melissa's shoes and
i'm walking through a heartbreaking
divorce and i've got this property in
the mobile and the fifth wheel and i've
got the car loans and the credit cards i
just want to simplify my life
is that what you want too
yes
okay
here's what that would look like for me
it means selling the house
getting out of it completely he takes
his portion i take my portion i sell the
employee stocks maybe look at even
selling the property and i just start
over and i go what is the future for
melissa look like now with a clean slate
with no payments in the world and a
giant pile of cash what would melissa do
if you had a pile of cash right now
would you go and buy that property and
buy that mobile home
no
i would buy
that tells your answer and count closer
to work boom
so now we can start doing some math and
go okay we're going to sell the stocks
we're going to sell the house we're
going to get my portion of that i'm
going to be it's a clean break i don't
need to mess with cash out refi and all
these things i'm going to sell the
property and now i have how much money
would you have
hundreds of thousands of dollars
yeah i projected like i said about three
hundred thousand in five years um and
you know
five years it wouldn't be five years how
much would you have today if you sold
everything
well
um and thought of that because i would
know where i would live well let's not
think five years out let's think about
six months you know where you'd live you
could get an apartment for a season
right you don't have to buy right away
you don't have to buy right away
i know but i have two big dogs
yeah i really live in an apartment with
two big dogs what are they horses
well well
they you know if i worked 12 hours a day
that there would be a lot of you know
bathroom
accidents all over the floor if you left
them in there there's something you know
78 pounds and still
okay so the dog and their doo-doo is
going to hold up you having a good plan
i know right
no like i said i own this other property
would that not be um a wise choice just
stay on this property i just pay the
property taxes and insurance which is
like and where are you going to live on
the property
in the fifth week
it's already set up yeah that's a
temporary solution but that doesn't
sound like melissa's future
no you can do that for a few months five
year five year plan i don't know if
that's so that's what you want for the
kids and the giant dogs
well the kids are grown up so it's just
me and the two dogs um and it's a half
acre for them to run around on i built a
uh six foot fence all the way around it
i think you keep the property in the
fifth wheel until you can get your own
place but this is not a five-year plan
yeah
yeah so sell your house and then we're
going to get rid of all the stock pay
off all the time yeah by the way the 18
year old
debt once i sell that home i can pay off
i could pay off a decent chunk now i
just like to have more in savings
especially being one income now
you're about to go through this storm
with this divorce and so we want you to
make as few decisions as possible and
only make the ones that are going to
free you up emotionally financially to
get you to whatever's next
so don't make any huge decisions we're
listening to you and just sell that
other house because that payment was
going to be really high i mean
we're just big fans of freedom it would
have been
yeah we don't want that's not going to
be a blessing no stress you've already
got enough going on
emotionally you don't need to put
pressure on yourself financially
so
yeah george is right
short term play on the property and the
minute you get stabilized get savings up
where you want to be for down payment
then sell that other property and cut up
the cards once they're paid off yeah you
don't need them cut them up now and then
pay them off but these are not a
blessing to you yeah i know i barely use
them um i really do i just had that one
because it had a zero percent but you
fell for the zero percent promotional
and now we're making payments i can pay
it off i'll pay i'll pay it off
you're a hard working person you can
fund your own fence
you don't need them yeah cut it up
before you pay it off cut the card up
they're not your friends all right well
thank you so much melissa there's a lot
going on in your life and we're wishing
you the best as you step forward and
hopefully the financial part once that's
cleaned up you can see the forest from
the trees and make some decisions out of
wisdom and calm that's what we want yeah
i hear stories like that and i loved
your advice george
and it just reminds me of something i've
heard said a million times
the best way to deal with complexity is
simplicity
when the life is so complex
the best way out of it is not adding
more i thought you were going to go with
henry david thoreau simplify simplify
simplify i knew you were going to pick
it up somehow george i knew if i handed
you the ball you were going to run up
the middle with it you just did the
sports analogy ken we were doing great
on the poetry and then you lost george i
have hope i have hope that i can bring
you into the fold to understand what
sports really are i missed the t on that
one there you go
hey more of the ramsay show coming up
and more terrible puns i'm george
campbell he's ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
i mean literally just the guys right now
i know finding that perfect gift for
that special lady in your life can feel
impossible but i got you i'm here for
you forget doom scrolling amazon lists
and pinterest boards just get her the
new 2023 ramsey goal planner now this
isn't just any box store gold planner
that you could get at the dollar store
target we literally took customer
suggestions from last year's version and
did a complete remix on it it's got a
gorgeous new cover that our amazing
design team produced and it's a more
convenient on-the-go size and it has new
monthly teachings from rachel cruz dr
john deloney and yours truly me george
campbell so what better way to show her
than you care than to give her a gift
that will inspire and motivate her to go
after her spiritual financial and
relationship goals
guys this is a gift she'll actually love
and that you'll actually use no guessing
on this one and our goal planners sell
out quickly every year we only get a
certain amount and every single year
they sell out so do not wait go get
yours today at ramseysolutions.com
planner that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash planner
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five aaron joins
us up next in indianapolis aaron can we
hear you loud and clear this time
yeah thanks for taking my time oh you
sound like a peach love it how can we
help today
that's right
yeah all right
i am uh currently in baby step two uh i
make about fifty five thousand dollars a
year and uh however my work is very
seasonal
i'm a flight instructor um
so
i've saved up about four thousand
dollars over the course of the summer
and i'm wondering if i should put that
towards my uh debt or if i should hold
that off for like a rainy day when the
winter time when the winter comes since
i'll be flying less in the wintertime my
income drops about
60-ish percent in the winter
can you pick up another job in the
winter time when things are slow
i actually currently have three jobs um
and i do pick up like seasonal work uh
in the wintertime
that i could do too but the income still
drops even with the additional jobs
it's just very hard for the the jobs to
schedule me because like if it's a good
weather day for example like the middle
of december you know i would make more
money flying than i would you know at a
you know you know packing boxes
but you're it's it's you're not sure
when you're gonna be working in the
wintertime
it's sporadic
well i wonder if something more steady
would even out to be more income than
that seasonal work in the winter
it feels like you've got this a little
bit uh reversed
um i certainly understand the math of
well if we have a really nice weather
day in in december then i'm going to
make more money getting out flying
um but
you you're putting at risk so much
income potential
and i would flip that i would go you
know what i'm going to spend most of my
time flying in the good weather months
and then come wintertime
i'm going to do something much more
stable or i'm going to start doing some
night shifts or whatever so if we do
have the occasional good weather day in
indianapolis and i think you know what
that weather pattern looks like i would
just make some moves to where we're
relying on
the three other side jobs or whatever
during the bad season or the winter
season rather
uh then i would just go well i'm going
to line these up but everything else
falls falls to the side
so that i can get up in the air
does it make sense it's just you're
you're not getting ahead when you could
be getting ahead
yeah that makes sense how much debt do
you have
uh about 77 000. i started out with 90
but paid off 13 while i was in college
what kind of debt is that
it's student loans also all 77 is
student loans
yeah ouch dude i what are your hours so
let's let's go to your real life
situation let's go to it's uh december
january and it's a good weather day in
indy what are the hours that you would
be flying
uh maximum i'm allowed to work by by law
is eight hours a day
i understand that i'm saying what's that
window usually look like is it usually
just during the day or does it include
some night time flying
it does include some nighttime flying so
i'm usually flying like 12 hours or i'm
usually in the office like 12 hours a
day from like seven to seven
yeah
i i just think you have to put that
aside i think you need steady really
good income work
uh what's the end game for you aaron are
you gonna you want to be a flight
instructor long term
uh no i want to make it to the airline
so that's why i'm building my hours now
okay how far are you into that process
um i am very close i have about
700 800 hours and i need a thousand so
i'm 200 hours shy okay and at that point
you could go apply and work at the
airlines making more money yeah
yep okay it sounds like until then we're
not gonna clean up this debt making 55
with 77 in front of us unless we are
working way over time taking other jobs
side hustles you name it
and so that's what i'm leaning towards
that option right now while you get your
hours or something else you could be
doing to clean up this debt
are there any other expenses you can
shave
um
i mean right now i'm living like produce
google illegally like i only live off of
like a thousand dollars a month yeah
this is all about income and i'm gonna
go back to what i told you earlier when
you said that makes sense so i'm gonna
repeat that in your brain
that's what this is this is an income
issue
and you can't get your income up you're
so close
but you've got to get your income up in
the off season
this is straightforward there's no other
option here you're young you don't need
to have a life
go work work work work work and knock
this debt out seventy seven thousand
dollars a lot of debt and you don't
wanna get into the airline and be
dragging all that debt along with you so
go after this thing
what was your degree in
aviation flight science okay cool so
we're using that at least oh yeah he's
on a great track
it's just we're not going to play this
well it's seasonal no
when i'm not flying when there's not a
lot of flying hours i am working my
fanny off
right now yeah
thanks for the question appreciate it
aaron keisha's up next in new york city
kisha welcome to the show
hi good afternoon thank you for taking a
call sure how can we help
okay all right i'm a little nervous so
um
i'm a registered nurse and i work for a
company i'm currently on my community
now
but i was unfortunately displaced um a
couple months um
after being in maternity leave i
recently um have a offer from the same
company for the emergency room
um but then i also have an offer for um
the oncology suite that i
that i used to work at but it's a
different unit it's not the same exact
unit but it's under the same management
but it's coming from like
kind of like a toxic
type of management so
um and another back story i'm also a
graduate student about to graduate for
my family and expectation in december do
i bite the bullet and go back to what i
know
or do i just
leave that toxic situation and go on to
embark in the eating for a couple months
until i get my career rolling
is that going to agree is that move that
you just gave us there the second option
so not going back to the toxic
environment but taking the second option
is that going to be an interruption in
income is it going to be the same amount
of income what's that going to look like
um so it would be like a lateral thing
it will be the same pay because we're
unionized so it's the same page then i
would do that
but but the [ __ ]
that the edie yeah i why would you go
back to toxicity when you're not going
to be there long term anyway right
true
so what's pulling you back towards that
um it's what you it's what you've done
i've been
yeah just comfortable i'm just gonna
tell you
i'm gonna tell you what it is
because i want you to i want you to
agree or disagree because i may be wrong
i think it's because you would rather be
um
comfortable in misery than uncomfortable
in something that you're not that's
something you don't know and so you go
oh it's miserable it's toxic but at
least i know what to expect and i can
get through it versus the change the
unknown
yes
you nailed it i know i've heard this
call a few thousand times
and it's okay to feel that way
it's natural because the change in the
unknown is horrifying sometimes but let
me just simplify it for you
do you have the ability to do this new
job and do it well
oh yeah absolutely and i'm a fast
learner you're a fast learner you got
high character high integrity don't you
yes i do what would have to be true for
you to fail miserably at that
you'd have to do something stupid yeah
not do it
do something stupid be lazy dishonest
none of those things are going to happen
you know that
take that position
and as you're finishing up the
credentialing and the education piece to
get you where you want to go try a new
environment hopefully a much healthier
environment don't go back to toxicity
just because you know it great wisdom
there thanks so much for the question
keisha that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books my thanks to ken
coleman my co-host all the folks in the
booth and you america we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studios this is the
ramsay show where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money i'm george campbell joined
this hour by my friend ken coleman and
we are happy and excited to take your
calls the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your look your life
your money your career whatever's going
on in your world scott joins us up first
in seattle scott welcome to the ramsey
show
george ken so happy to meet you thanks
for taking the time to talk with me
in particular your proximity principle
got me
uh one of my most recent jobs oh that's
awesome man great to hear thank you yeah
how can we help today
so i've got a family finance question um
the gist of it is should i buy my
parents a home
with my brothers
a little bit of backstory
i'm in my early 30s my brothers are also
similarly aged
parents are in their early 70s they
my dad can't work he has a genetic
disease my mom is probably gonna have to
stop working to take care of my dad
they unfortunately don't have retirement
savings they just have social security
so the alternatives are like do we pay
their rents
do we put them in low-income housing
do we build an in-law unit on one of our
properties
so yeah kind of a whopper
well let's take off the low-income
housing right that's not really an
option is it
it doesn't seem like it because it's
going to take a few years probably for
them to wait on the list
and uh you know i just i worry about it
being safe so yeah you guys i know that
that's why just let's take that off the
list you you and your brothers are good
dudes you're not gonna allow that to
happen are they renting right now you
said
they are they're renting near me in
seattle uh rents about two thousand
dollars a month for a small one-bedroom
couch
yeah it hurts
and you need them close by i mean could
they live somewhere further out that's
less expensive so it's a good question
um the leading um case for us our
leading candidate is to move them down
to huntsville alabama which is where my
brother's based
and he'd be there he'd be their family
point of contact we could
either have really cheap rent or buy
them a small house for a lot more
affordable what it costs up here in
seattle
i like that plan better are they willing
to do that
um they don't really have any options
yeah they don't have options they're
kind of stuck we are their retirement
plan kind of unfortunate but that's how
it is
um tell me in about a month
i'm sorry tell me tell me real quick
about the option of uh
adding on to one of the brother's house
for the in-law suite how how viable is
that and where would that be
it would probably it's probably my wife
in my house up here in seattle that has
the best space for it um
it's a risk because there's no financial
roi for my brothers if we buy them a
house um or if we extend our house right
like we're probably not going to give my
brothers equity in our home if they
contribute honestly oh and so you would
need you would need their contribution
to be able to afford it
that's right and they would never get
that contribution back so this would
just be
a gift probably not can you guys afford
if we walk george through the huntsville
situation what kind of house
who's how much are we putting in can you
afford it do you have the cash to put in
your part of the down payment
yeah yeah so we've got right now we're
looking at homes that are under three
hundred thousand dollars
um
kind of two to three bedrooms
uh
a thousand to 1200 square feet
why do they need three bedrooms
you know this is where it's tricky
because we're buying a house for tenants
who are our parents
and uh
they really want an extra bedroom to
host
uh well
that's two bedrooms not three
i know i know
it's a it's a good good question they
don't get to have a wishlist two-bedroom
house it probably should you guys are
paying for it you go mom and dad we're
gonna get you two-bedroom that's it
you can have guests in the living room
they got things called air mattresses
you know i was thinking about that it's
probably for the amount of cost it's
gonna be to buy them a three-bedroom i
could just get a hotel when i visit well
if families come through could they not
stay with the brothers
yeah but this just feels like a
non-issue i think we get the most
affordable house possible
when it's you guys put in the bill and
are they in a financial spot to
contribute have you talked to them about
that
yeah we've talked money um we could do
for sure 20 20 down um maybe more um
and uh
yeah potentially if it was a 200 000
house we could probably do 30
down and so their social security if you
do that if you and whatever they've got
plus the brothers are they going to be
able to cover their rent and their
budget from their social security yeah
we're not going to charge them brent
we're just going to view it as a as a
long term so you and the brothers are
splitting up the mortgage payment
yeah
are your brothers pushing you to do the
three-bedroom or is it just mama
uh there's a bit of brother pushing yeah
bro i'm gonna tell you george i got all
kinds of red flags on this this just
sounds like a messy situation even down
the road
trying to split this house it feels
messy why not just cover their rent in
huntsville
and split that yeah
as long as they're on this earth
part of that idea yeah but i can just
tell you right now your brothers who are
pushing for the three bedroom and the
roi and all that they're not going to
want to pay rent they want they feel
like they want something back
that's right oh i know i can hear i got
the whole thing
well it feels like dude listen i gotta
tell you right now this is this may be
very unpopular but
i happen to be one of the co-hosts today
and you caught um i would i would tell
my brothers here's what i'm willing to
do
yeah you also come to an agreement at
some point and if you guys aren't
willing to do that that's totally cool
you guys figure it out
but i'm willing to
i'm willing to contribute to a
two-bedroom
and we need to have an agreement written
up
that we all sign that says when we sell
this house it's equal parts you know and
you can get a real estate attorney and i
get a real estate attorney absolutely
everything needs to be on paper and
there ain't no discussion about no
handshake agreements no handshakes no i
promise we're good none of that or i
would walk from it and go mom dad i'm
sorry
i i can't contribute to this and you
gotta tell your brother same thing
that's really good the real estate
attorney piece is one we've talked about
but um i think is there there are so
many cooks in the kitchen we haven't
gotten that how many brothers are we
talking
it's me and two brothers okay see i
think you need to take on the chief cook
roll for a couple of days and go hey
guys here's what we're doing if you want
me involved
yeah
yeah you're right my wife's been saying
similar things too we need to have more
clearly lined up like roles
responsibilities obligations who's doing
what who's going to cover the hvac when
it goes out and who's going to go over
there and this is we've got a real i
think you all need to get on a zoom call
this week and go guys we gotta talk we
gotta talk through every nitty-gritty
detail or else this is gonna turn into
broken relationships down the road but
scott you have to say this is what has
to happen
for me to be involved and if not guys
i'm cool i'm out
your wife is right listen to your wife
oh that's some good advice a timeless
wisdom yeah from the spouse there ken
has learned oh boy still trying to learn
it's going to be a messy situation no
matter which way you slice it i just
don't want to see any broken
relationship over this and so we've got
to be real clear because to be unclear
is to be unkind wishing you the best
with this man this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and the
entree leadership podcast joined by ken
coleman host of the ken coleman show you
can check out those shows on the ramsey
network or wherever you listen to
podcasts
natalie joins us up next in portland
oregon natalie welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
happy to take it what's going on
um so i have kind of a career question i
just came across a job posting for a job
that i would love to have eventually and
um
i'm thinking about reaching out to this
company and seeing if they could
use me as an unpaid intern and i'm just
i'm wondering if uh that'd be a good
idea to ask and uh what would be the
best way to ask like should i email go
in person that'd be weird i'm just not
sure yeah i love this by the way uh i've
employed this strategy and i love it but
before i tell you what to do are you do
you need uh you've got a you've got an
income situation coming in or you're
okay to be able to go do this like this
isn't going to affect you negatively if
you get this
um i mean i have a full-time job but my
hours are really flexible so i would
i don't think i could swing this full
time but i i could do like yeah but for
an internship great okay that's all i
wanted to make sure of so this is going
to be bonus for you to get the
experience and the connections that's
why we're doing this and i love this
so here's how you approach this i want
you to try to approach this in person
so do we know somebody that knows
somebody over there in the department
that you want to intern for have you
narrowed it down to that like i know i
want to do i want to intern for somebody
who's doing this or in this department
this kind of work have you narrowed that
down i assume you have
yeah i i don't know anyone at the
company though but i'll bet you know
somebody who knows somebody
true or false think about that one for a
second now i don't think you can i don't
think you can actually confirm that
but the question is you think about all
the people you know
is the company in your area of portland
yes it is how many people do you know i
want you to give me just a loose
ballpark guess how many people do you
know that's everything from close
personal connections to acquaintances
in portland how many people would you
say you know
not many i'm not from here
okay just give me a number
i'm going somewhere with this
uh
do you know 10 people
maybe okay okay so you're brand new to
the area right
i
kind of i mean
i've been here for a while but the
company is out that i work for is out of
state
um so you're working remote and all that
okay here's my exercise okay the point
is if you know 10 people
how many people do you think those 10
people know give me a number
i i
hundreds hundreds
so here's my point let's start with the
10 people you know and go look
um i'm interested in making a connection
over at company abc whatever the name of
the company is okay i literally want you
to start there because i think you'll be
surprised what might turn up
uh because if we before we go into just
walking in off the street uh or reaching
out via email or phone i want you to do
all right so i want you to do the whole
thing but i'd love for you to find out
who is in charge
of the department that you want to work
for do you already know that have you
gone on the website and figured out who
it is a real person's name
no i haven't okay that's where we start
okay
so we go to that website we find out
linkedin whatever we dig and you can do
this natalie you know you can you can
find out who is in charge of that
division or department where you would
love to intern we start there now we got
a name okay
so i want you to write a handwritten
note to that person
handwritten note okay hey listen i have
a full-time job it's very flexible i
want to intern
for free i don't need any money i'm
willing to work for free because i want
to get some valuable experience and
learn more about this industry because
i've got plans to do this this and this
and uh if you're willing to meet with me
for five minutes so that you can get to
know me i can send you my resume so you
can get background references on me are
you willing to take somebody like me for
some free help someone who will work
hard like they're paid full time like
that's a really interesting way to go
about this i would do it in a
handwritten note i would try to do it
via email and i would also leave the
same voicemail so all three things boom
boom boom we're hitting them from three
different angles you still with me
natalie
yes and and listen enthusiasm
and hunger is what we want and i just
kind of gave you a version a way to
write it way to say it that's what we're
going to do now in the meantime
while we've done that we're looking for
any type of connection to
that building or somebody in that
building who could go talk to that
person on your behalf go hey i heard
great things about this gal natalie
she'd love to just come in she wants to
shadow work for free add value any way
she can just to get some valuable
experience and learn more about the
industry and the job
that's how you're going to go about this
but if we can make a personal connection
to where someone can put a good word in
for you and you've got the email the
handwritten note and the voicemail
i think that is a really good way to go
about by the way add to what i just said
linkedin
instagram twitter twitter if you can
contact them that way too after you've
already sent the note after you sent the
email and after you've left the
voicemail
how old are you natalie
24. okay what kind of social media do
you use at 24.
fill me in
uh
i don't have any zero
today might be the day to start james
our producer loves it he's a big privacy
nerd but it might be time to make a
profile and follow some folks that work
there and just engage
yeah and just respond you don't have to
be like creepy and be like hey can we
get a coffee meeting tomorrow it may
just be hey that's awesome love what you
guys do over there yeah and over time
they go oh i've noticed that username
and then you go hey i noticed you guys
are doing this kind of work and i would
love are there any opportunities that
you guys know about i would love to just
can you get me in touch with someone
my job here started as an internship
natalie
and it started because of a tweet and
the tweet turned into a dm the dm turned
to a phone call that phone call turned
into a zoom and that turned into a paid
internship that turned into a full-time
role and it all just spiraled because i
was proactive i was enthusiastic and i
wouldn't take no for an answer and i was
willing to do any job there
in the door and that's george you're
like 10 x
he is
so smart george is obnoxious i mean
imagine george contacting you all the
time but you natalie with a winning
personality it's going to be great and
here's the thing i'm having fun at
george's expense he's awesome and george
did it the right way by the way natalie
here's what i'm trying to tell you most
kids your age will look down their nose
at doing an internship without pay it's
all about dignity and i deserve to be
paid and all this stuff no you're just
trying to get in so i kind of i just
want to applaud you your hunger and your
desire to step into this i think it's i
think you're gonna be surprised at how
easy this is gonna turn out for you to
get this what kind of work are you doing
now and what's the new one you're
looking to jump into
um
i i do a
weird job now that's not really
a job anywhere else
which is it's really fun but
i just i worry if something happens to
this company i would have to
start at the very bottom somewhere
um we do like surgical planning but i
want to get into medical device design
cool so that's the nature of the company
that's what they do that you want to
internet
yes yes they're a real medical device
company one other thing i want to give
you is
hold the word intern loosely
because some people may hear that and go
well we don't have an actual official
internship situation if you just go look
i want to come in and work for free and
help out and just kind of get get in and
listen to a shadow for a shadow help out
work i'll do it i just really want to
learn more about this injury that is so
attractive and so rare
um
i i think it's going to work for you did
that help you i hope
it did she's on hold now oh you already
put up she's with god thank you but uh
ken for a lot of folks that are out
radio guns especially yes especially
those that are younger
they're kind of getting out of school
going all right i got the piece of paper
where's my job
wait where's my six-figure salary no
one's knocking on my door yeah and then
you get someone like natalie who goes
i'm willing to do whatever
it takes i agree
and we're we're great at teaching kids
the no you know the textbooks but we
don't actually teach them how to go
about getting the job
well you're right we've lost the art of
just connecting with people and say hey
would you be willing to give me a shot
that's really attractive
you know and it beats your application
in a digital pile somewhere with some
algorithm
learning to fly
but i ain't got wings there you go
perfect bump as we end this segment
good wisdom there ken thank you natalie
for the call this is the ramsay show
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
listen we know a lot of you are scared
right now between inflation and debt
payments you feel like you're drowning
and you're terrified you won't have
enough to take care of your family but
you shouldn't have to live in fear
but you have to get to the point where
you say i've had it and then decide that
you are ready to make a change
because you can't keep doing the same
things with money and expect different
results and that means it's time to try
out something different a different plan
financial peace university this is the
course that will teach you our
step-by-step plan to beat debt save for
emergencies and build wealth it worked
for me and it's worked for 10 million
people and right now we're offering it
at the lowest price ever so stop living
in fear you can take control of your
money with financial peace university
get started right now go to
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's
slash
ramseysolutions.com
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this hour phone lines are open
triple eight eight two five five two two
five ben joins us in des moines ben
welcome to the show
good afternoon thanks for having me on
sure how can we help
uh so i got a question for you guys i
start i started listening a couple
months ago took me about 10 years to
get out the program and realized that
was actually legit
and now i'm in baby step number two and
uh almost gazelle intense
um
i'm hoping to do a lifelong
dream of mine of it's a career change to
be a helicopter pilot that's
a dream i know it's very far-fetched but
i'm wondering if there's
any like where do i put it in the baby
steps do i start school
you know somewhere after being
completely debt-free because i know it's
really
really expensive to do
how expensive is it
i'm looking at about a hundred twenty
thousand dollars and i wanna cash flow
it or
get scholarships if possible hundred
twenty thousand forty seven there's only
so much okay 120 000 to get your that
particular helicopter i mean how
specific is this
um that's a rough estimate for uh again
the private pilot's license the
commercial and instrument ratings so you
can actually get paid to do it right
and there's not a there's not a way to
kind of uh and forgive the ignorance
here but i is there not a way to get in
on a lower level of some type of
helicopter and work your way up or is it
just all or nothing you can't you can't
fly until you get to a certain to the
120 000.
well i looked at my the local airport
around here and uh for twenty thousand
dollars you can get your private pilot
license and then you can fly people for
free um
and build up your hours eventually you
need to get more pay more to get your
instrument rating so you can fly in
adverse weather conditions lower
visibility and uh commercial rating is
to get uh be able to get paid for it so
it's kind of progression uh 120 000
would get me all that to where i can
actually be employable how long would it
take you to save up if you're going to
cash flow how long is going to take you
to to to get to that kind of cash flow
situation
um i'm not 100 sure my debt free date
according to the app is um
september of 24
um
and then
i guess the app doesn't really project
out from there as far as unless i'm
using it wrong but how much debt do you
have
for
my home equity loan and my car is all i
have and that would be forty nine
thousand dollars okay what's the car
worth
um about five thousand what do you owe
on it
and then the home equity loan is the
rest
yep i traded in the chevy silverado to
get
a lot of it down so thanks
good that would help so what's your
income right now
uh somewhere around sixty thousand
dollars
what do you do
i'm a local trucker
a local what
a local truck driver
okay you married family what's going on
there oh yes i got an 11 year old
daughter and a wife that works for the
schools
and total household income is 60
uh mine is 60 hers brings it up to about
75.
what could you do in the short term
to maybe get a 20 25 30 000 race
well i was that's why i said i'm almost
gazelle intense because i could go over
the road and make some more money but
i'm worried about how that would affect
the family yeah i get that
i get that but for a season
a few months
say that again could you do it for a few
months
um i'm not sure
i think that's an interesting
conversation to have with your wife i
mean if you could do it even for a year
right
and it were to fast forward
uh paying off that debt now you're going
to be able to stockpile some cash and
truly cash flow your way through
this helicopter journey i i
first of all you can do it it just
depends on how intense you want to be
like you could pay off the debt and
start doing the you know a portion of
the 20 000 local thing just to kind of
go ahead and get that done
you're not doing it all at once but you
are getting at least some of that
experience and you could cash flow if
you went out there and work some
overtime or whatever and you kept paying
off the debt but then you had you know
you
you can do this you just have to decide
how long you're willing to wait
okay
um would it be advisable to wait till
after baby step three
um
or
i mean it's gonna free up your income so
you can cash flow it faster so what
ken's saying is you could split the
difference and start paying off the debt
and cash flow you know a semester of the
training
or whatever that looks like yeah and get
started
i'm saying walk our baby steps out
so the baby steps are the baby steps
you're gonna pay the debt off and you're
gonna get to three to six months in baby
step three but what i'm saying is with a
little bit of extra effort you can at
least
incrementally move your way down the
line and cash flow that so that once
you're done with baby step three you
don't have as much to do or as much to
save is your wife working full-time
yes she is and she's making 15 a year
yeah it's not very good see there's
another area i mean
what would she have to do or what could
she do where she was making three times
that amount
i've tried to work with her again in a
new career but she's she's had a lot of
jobs where she didn't love her job and
she's
she finally loves her job so she's
pretty hesitant to make so what is she
doing at the schools
she works with severely disabled uh
physically mentally disabled kids
and she's looked at all the jobs in the
area to see what the options are and
what they pay
yeah the other school districts are
similar and it's paying basically it
sounds like it's minimum wage
yeah it's pretty bad
that's a tough one because i know she's
comfortable and that's you know based on
her experience but i mean you guys
listen this is an income play
this is just increasing your income
and if you the quicker you increase the
income the quicker you get through the
debt and the quicker you get up in the
air
so
um
i i tend to be a guy who's always going
to prescribe going after it as hard as
you can
and getting through it and you know your
daughter's 11
you know
you know you're bit you've been around
it's not like you're going to disappear
but if she sees her dad take on a goal
and and and sacrifice and and hustle and
grind i mean that's only going to be a
great object lesson for her how old are
you how old are you ben
i am 41. 41. oh i was my job with the
ramsey junior program so she's
really on board with that
when do you want to be flying a
helicopter
is this like an encore career he wants
to be up there tonight
and so what are you willing to do if
you're saying i want to do this today
because if that's true then i'm going to
have a fire under my butt and i'm going
to be working 80 hours a week and so i'm
not worried about how driving over the
road is going to affect my family for a
season if that means i'm going to get to
this dream a whole lot faster because 10
years from now this is still a dream
you're going to be really frustrated
beating yourself up
yes
yeah
then you've probably already had this
stream long before this
since kindergarten since kindergarten
and so for 41 years you've been batting
this around but we got to stop playing
the games we got to stop going into debt
because it's slowing us down it's
delaying us from the dream
so i think you need to have a little
dream date with your wife and go what
are we willing to do to make this dream
happen are you willing to switch careers
are you okay then if you're not willing
for me to do over the roads that we can
clean up this debt faster
okay
and get her on board with the vision
because until then it's gonna be i don't
think i want you on the road but we
don't make enough money we're just gonna
be sitting in 50 000 of debt
and that's just not a future that i'm
okay with i don't think you are either
so do whatever it takes follow ken's
advice and i hope you call us back and
go i got the helicopter license
that would make ken's soul just scream
with joy i wouldn't mind a ride in the
old whirlybird i'm too scared those
things frighten me but i'm happy for you
ben good luck man this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 14 23
all hard work brings a profit but mere
talk leads only to poverty
thomas jefferson once said i'm a great
believer in luck and i find the harder i
work the more i have of it tj
you love a good tj i love me some thomas
jefferson quotes do you think anyone
called it
uh i no nobody called him tj well you
know what that begs a very interesting
question back in the day would would
they they knew their names and they were
writing would someone go hey man honey
how you doing tj like did gw see him in
philadelphia and go what's up tj i doubt
they talk like bros so that
throws me off the center of the trail on
that one
all right last segment of the hour you
can still give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five tish
joins us in houston tish welcome to the
show
thank you so much i'm a new listener and
we love
thank you for loving me i'm so glad you
guys took my call how can we so my
situation is my situation is this i'm
i'm in my early 50s i have less than 50
000 in retirement i took on a second job
so i have two full-time jobs to try and
catch up on my retirement and i'm kind
of scared out of my mind
what's scaring you
i don't i don't have a plan i don't
really have a strategy to get me caught
up i mean
i have i've taken on a second job but i
don't know what to do now like what do i
do what's your total income
um
the second job now i'm at 120 120 000.
love it
and where are you investing if at all
so i i normally do through my job um i i
just connected to a new investor well
and and um financial advisor and he's
only investing like 7 000 into uh ira
for me
and that's pretty much it i i'm really
new at investing i don't i don't know
what to do but i need to do was this one
of our smart investor pros or did you
find one outside of that
no
i i i'm a new listener i did not know
better okay well hey the good news is
it's not too late uh so i would reach
out to one of our smart investor pros
and here's why they can actually educate
you and help you feel confident in what
you're investing in instead of going hey
i gave this guy some money and i think
he's investing it into an ira
i want you to fully understand what
we're doing
and so okay because you don't know what
that's invested in
because the ira is just a show
i don't even know how to read the the
statement
um
well that's where we're gonna start
because if you're following our baby
steps have you heard about those
yes i'm on baby step one but i i was
already saving for the in case something
happened so i kind of skipped around
because i was when i found you guys i
was already in the process of saving
just in case something happened which is
step three well how much does that do
that's the thing i only have my car and
since i found you i'm gonna go ahead and
pay the car off with the step three
okay so how much money do you have in
the bank and then i have a mortgage
so right now i have about 33 000. 33 in
the bank and what's on the car loan
um just 10. okay we're paying that off
today
yeah so that leaves you with 23 which is
going to be your fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and now we're now we're zooming because
now you freed up that payment right
what's the car payment
it was only like 340 something like that
only do you know what 340 thousand 340
invested every month could do for you
no i don't
paint the picture jordan so you're going
to use the power of compound interest
you said you're in your 50s which means
you could live another 30 years easily
now think about 30 years of compound
growth
on thousands and thousands of dollars a
year
so let's say you had ten percent return
on a hundred thousand dollars how much
is that
ten grand ten percent return ten
now you have 110. the next year ten
percent return guess how much you have
11 000
and you see how compound interest starts
to work for you
yeah so that's what's going to get you
excited over the next many years as you
begin to catch up on this retirement the
good news is you're willing to work for
it aren't you
you're working two full-time jobs in
your 50s
yeah i'm about to do another season
online yeah i'm ready i love it well use
this fewer the fear to fuel you to doing
this stuff for the next 10 years so that
you can retire with dignity with no
house payment in the world no debt how
would that feel
that will feel amazing i love it that
looks so amazing jump onto
ramseysolutions.com click on ramsay
recommends and get in touch with one of
our smartvestor pros and they can guide
you through this process and pay off
that car today do not wait don't let
this debt sit around while you're
burning 340 bucks a month that could go
to your future
thanks for the call tish all right
claudia is going to end us off here in
miami florida claudia welcome to the
show
thank you thank you for taking my call
sure what's going on
my question is should i buy instead of
rent
i have a pa um a home already paid
you have a paid for house
yes
and you're going to buy another house
well i got my i transferred to miami
from georgia
so i i had to come because of my job and
now i had a rent to be able to work
okay so you're renting the paid for
houses in georgia
yes okay and why are you hanging on to
it
my kids live in it they're going they're
going to school
uh they go to college both both of my
kids are going to college so instead of
paying a dorm
or um
paying an apartment they can stay in the
house okay that's a good plan
and you're wondering should i buy
another house in florida here versus
rent
yes
do you plan on staying in miami long
term
um i would say maybe five years
maybe less how much money do you have
in the bank twenty eight thousand
okay does that include your emergency
fund
yes okay and you're debt free
yes okay
so right now i would rent because we
need to save up a down payment if we're
going to purchase a home
okay so that would be the next step can
you rent for a year or two and then make
a decision
and just stack up cash i can't
yeah i i wouldn't do that i would do
that claudia i just want to bring in
another component to what george is
giving you here and that is that you
really don't know what's going to happen
next year
two years from now three years from now
four years from now five years from now
and uh we know you're not going to be in
miami long term we do know that correct
well
right now i'm not really sure i moved
and i really love my job i love what i'm
doing and i'm not really sure if this is
where i'm going to stay or right so am i
going to move so whenever we are
uncertain renting is always the best
option because of that last word rent
allows you options flexibility
flexibility
okay okay because you're in good
financial position
right you got to pay for home back in
georgia once the kids are out of school
that's a tremendous asset for you if you
want to go back to it to live in there's
that if you end up loving miami and you
know then you go okay maybe i do want to
buy here well you know renting until you
have the right down payment is the right
play anyway so i just think renting is
the smart decision here i don't think a
lot of people tell
folks like you that renting can be the
best decision and in this case it is the
best decision because it gives you
flexibility what's the house worth in
georgia
the house is probably 400 000.
the kids will be there for the next four
years
yes
okay
so four years from now what if you
rented for four years and then the kids
are out and you can go all right i love
it here i think i'm gonna stay let me go
ahead and sell the house in georgia and
i can use all of that money to buy
something in miami on top of the pile of
cash i've saved up for four years
sounds good that would give me some
freedom
that would instead of now i've got a
mortgage on this miami home plus i don't
know what i'm going to do with this
georgia home that's just sitting there
and i'm paying property taxes and
homeowners insurance on it
so i think that might be the play is
let's get the kids through college let's
rent let's save up a huge pile of cash
and we can make a decision down the road
sounds good thanks so much for the call
way to go claudia all right thank you
thank you very much nice to be george
have you been to miami
you know my wife is a huge fan i've been
through it i don't know that i've
experienced it i could see you walking
on south beach with like white socks and
the black flip-flops i'm pretty sure i
would get arrested for just being so
pale that i'm a i'm a nuisance to the
public
yeah there's like solar flares going on
everyone is tanned there yeah yeah it's
a great place i love me some miami i
would love to go i want to get just in
the food there all the food needs some
of that cupid's great cuban fair yeah i
love me some miami food well now i'm
hungry and that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books my thanks to
ken coleman my co-pilot all the folks in
the booth and you america we appreciate
you listening we'll be back with you
before you know it until then spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you